[Music]
I miss you so much I miss you too Mama
will you be careful out there
always mommy I'm very happy to be back
home
H H but things are
different
I have a piano in my house and I don't
play the
[Music]
piano do you have hallucinations
Mama
yeah astronauts go through things they
don't understand that's when people come
unstuck when I was up there the only
thing I could focus on was getting back
to my daughter let Miss see Mommy will
you be careful out there Mommy who who
was that that was you and me right
before the
accident that was not
me m where is
she
you I invented a machine we took into
space and I saw something but it seems
like it doesn't want to be
seen he these things up
there and when they get back they go
crazy this isn't
Madness you need to help
me I need to go back to
her do I seem the same to
you I just don't feel like you're my mom
[Music]
huh